there is additional Security in that  additional security at Clark County  election headquarters in North Las Vegas  there are security cameras monitored by  Metro Police and there will be  additional security guards along with  the police presence according to Clark  County Register of Voters Joe Gloria  Clark County Register of Voters Joe  Gloria telling eight news now the county  is more prepared after some lessons  learned from the previous election cycle  in part because of false claims about  election fraud  those have been claims that have been  disproven there were several court cases  that went in in 2020 and none of them  are successful the county given a tour  to members of the media today showing  the areas where ballots are sorted  signatures are verified and other  aspects of the voting process